will this help you stay motivated let's
find out so we need a lot of reading and
researching about visual cues as they
relate to building habits and there's
been a lot of data and studies showing
that when you make something visual and
put in front of you you're much more
likely to follow through on the habit
that you're trying to build the most
famous example in pop culture might be
the Seinfeld don't break the chain
example where whatever goal you have
whether it's work out every day or
whatever it is you put it up on the wall
and you want to put an X on every day so
you don't break that chain and just by
having that visual chart somewhere helps
make sure that you follow through on it
as opposed to just telling yourself I
want to make sure I do this every day
another example a guy wants to make
sales calls and here's a goal to make a
hundred sales calls a day and he has one
jar full of paperclips and one jar is
empty and every time that he makes a
sales call he takes one paper clip from
this jar and puts it into this jar and
he keeps making the calls until this
chair is empty and this jar is full he's
made his hundred calls and that visual
cue helps make sure that he's on track
and so habit forming and seeing
motivated and follow it through is a
huge issue for entrepreneurs and I want
to try to think of a way to help you
guys stay motivated and follow through
and the main reason why I started this
channel was to give you ideas and
motivations and strategies to build a
successful business have a significant
impact on the world and i would like to
figure out how to use the channel as a
way to make it a visual cue for you to
have success in your company and so
here's what i've come up with let me
know what you think my idea is to use
the comment system as a visual cue where
every day you would come and watch a
video and leave a comment and next to
the comment would be something like DC
one which would stand for days connected
one or days commented one and then the
next day would come back and do DC two
of the next a dc-3 in DC for and then if
you ever miss a day you have to start
over when you do come back you're back
to DC
I'm not a huge fan of the name DC days
commented seems very blonde boring so if
you have a better name or idea I love
for you to share that in the comments
below and when I'm hoping it does is not
only keeps you back and watching the
videos but staying on track and staying
on pattern and keeping that habit
building to drive your business forward
one of the things that I found in my
life in other people's lives is habits
can be a chain reaction so if you have a
habit where you want to work out every
day and you have that X for your
marketing every day if you wake up and
you do it and you're on track that helps
set you up for the rest of the day to be
successful you're much more likely to
stick to the diet that you're supposed
to be on you much more likely to do the
business tax that you supposed to do for
that day you much more likely to have a
happier day treat your wife better treat
your kids better your day just goes
better when you start yourself on the
right path where if you know you're
supposed to work out and you miss that
day you're much more likely to fall off
track for everything else during the day
it creates a negative chain reaction you
miss your workout you're much more
likely to not have a healthy meal eat
that chocolate bar go check that
Frappuccino you much you're much more
likely not to follow through on the
business goals that you set for yourself
then you're going to have a frustrating
day you're going to come home and not be
happy and be angry and you know be
miserable and I want to try to be a
positive chain reaction I want to try to
set that off with you guys so every day
you're set up for success and so my idea
is to do it to the comments and I love
to know your feedback of one do you
think it's a good idea and two what's a
good name for right I'm really curious
to know your thoughts I really hope it
could be something to help you stay
motivated and drive your business
forward and I also get some
encouragement for the other
entrepreneurs that are part of the
channel where people see that you're you
know dc1 and say hey you're starting off
and you have a good luck congratulations
or if your DC 30 hey congrats on making
our way to 30 days you know I think that
encouragement of support can help you
stay motivated and drive
to achieve all your your business goals
and stay on track so that's my thought
let me don't you think I'm curious I
haven't seen anybody do this before so
it's a risk but we're all about
experimenting leave your comments below
thank you guys for watching believe